Hello again, dear viewers.
You know what it is and what it does.
It being The Anom-O-Tron 6000, our hyper-advanced
simulation computer.
IT also being one of today’s combatants,
the horrifying creature created by Stephen
King in his 1986 novel - the most popular
form of this shapeshifting, fear-eating monster
being Pennywise the Dancing Clown.
And we thought…
What if Pennywise met the SCP Foundation’s
resident lover of fear, SCP-2006, also known
as Too Spooky?
Well, let’s turn on the device and find
out!
It was the summer of 1989, and for all across
the United States, it was the time of freedom,
of childhood wonder, splashing through creeks
searching for frogs, flying kites, and riding
their bikes as fast and as far as they could
before it was time to be home for dinner.
At the SCP Foundation, however, there was
no summer break.
No lazy days lounging by the pool, no trips
to the corner ice cream shop to sample every
flavor before finally picking one, and certainly
no trips to the beach.
He never thought he'd say this, but Agent
Adams was beginning to miss dumping sand out
of his shoes at the end of a long day, tending
to the sunburn he always seemed to get.
Instead, he was working, sitting on board
a Foundation-owned helicopter, staring down
at the beautiful sun-soaked landscape below
and wishing he too could be having a little
bit of Summer fun.
But there was no time to dwell on the past,
no day for daydreams.
He needed to bring his attention back to the
task at hand: transporting this anomaly to
its new containment site.
It was hard to keep himself focused, he had
to admit.
There wasn't much company on board.
It was just him, the pilot, the shy, quiet
Agent Paul, and SCP-2006.
Adams didn't know too much about the entity,
he had to admit.
He hadn't seen too much of it, only crossed
paths with it once or twice.
Currently, it was contained in a miniature,
portable version of its airtight containment
cell.
The little he had seen of the creature had
been confusing, and, to be honest, a little
bit ridiculous.
It was hairy, sort of like a gorilla but more
like a man in a cheap gorilla Halloween costume,
and wore an old-school space helmet on its
head, complete with two goofy antennae jutting
out of the top.
He had laughed out loud when he first saw
it, but a supervisor had reprimanded him harshly,
and promised that if he was caught laughing
at SCP-2006 again, he would be reassigned
to a far more dangerous anomaly.
He didn't want to screw around with that SCP-682
or SCP-106, so he made sure to stifle his
urge to giggle the next time he saw the absurd
creature.
Now, sitting on the helicopter, listening
to the whirring of the blades and wishing
he had thought to bring a book, he couldn't
help but ponder the nature of the entity he
was helping transport.
"So, what's this thing's deal?"
He asked Agent Paul, who had been silently
working on a newspaper crossword puzzle he
brought with him.
"What, SCP-2006?"
"Yeah, what's up with it?
It's kind of...silly, right?"
Agent Paul's eyes widened, and he put a finger
to his lips.
"Shh!
You can't say stuff like that."
Agent Adams held up his hands in surprise.
"Whoa, buddy, sorry to offend."
"No, no."
Agent Paul shook his head.
"You don't get it.
We need to act like this thing is terrifying.
Got it?"
He lowered his voice.
"I know it's kind of funny, when I first saw
the thing it transformed into a killer tomato
from an old movie for crying out loud, but
the higher-ups don't want it to figure out
what actually scares people.
So we have to play along.
Like when a little kid jumps out from behind
a chair in a monster mask and you give them
a big fake scream so they can feel powerful.
It's like that.
Only the fate of humanity rests in the balance."
Agent Adams couldn't help himself at that
comment.
"Seriously?
How does protecting this thing's ego affect
the fate of humanity?"
Agent Paul rolled his eyes so hard it looked
like he might hurt himself.
"Because, Adams.
This is a creature whose only goal in the
world, its favorite thing to do, its entire
life's purpose, is to scare human beings.
That's all it wants.
Right now, it's not that great at it because
its idea of what's scary is based on a bunch
of horrible drive-in horror movies from the
50s, but if it ever figured out the kind of
stuff that really scares people?
I mean really, truly, pee your pants level
scares people?
Who knows what it would do?
Imagine if, say, this thing got a look at
SCP-173.
Or even a more recent horror movie, like what
if this thing saw A Nightmare on Elm Street
and decided to start cutting people up with
Freddy Kreuger hands?
Seriously, you need to learn to think before
you speak."
Agent Adams nodded thoughtfully, taking in
the surprising outburst from such a usually
quiet guy.
"Well okay, dang, I had no idea."
"Maybe you should pay more attention during
briefings."
Agent Paul snarked.
Adams was just about to retort, when the helicopter
suddenly veered to the left with a lurch.
There was a grinding sound, metal on metal,
and it quickly became apparent that something
was wrong with the helicopter.
"Something's wrong, I've never seen anything
like this before!"
The pilot shouted from his position at the
controls.
"This thing's going down, and we're going
to have to jump if we don't want to go down
with it!"
"What about SCP-2006?"
Agent Paul panicked.
"Unless it has a parachute, we'll have to
leave it to fend for itself!"
The pilot was already suiting up with his
own emergency parachute, making his way to
the door of the helicopter.
"I suggest you get moving if you don't feel
like exploding today!"
That was all Agent Adams needed to shock him
out of his temporary crisis-induced paralysis.
He grabbed the last two parachutes on board,
tossed one to the pale, extremely sweaty Agent
Paul, and prepared to make the jump to what
would hopefully be safety.
He patted the side of SCP-2006's mobile containment
unit halfheartedly.
"Sorry, buddy."
was all he could think to say before he took
a deep breath, tried not to throw up, and
followed the pilot, diving out of the helicopter
toward the ground below.
He heard Agent Paul jump out right behind
him, and soon the only sound he could hear
was the roaring of the wind in his ears as
his fingers fumbled with the ripcord on his
harness.
He pulled it, and the parachute ballooned
out, doing its job and carrying him slowly
down to earth.
He landed with a grunt, feeling around for
any broken bones.
Thankfully, he had landed smoothly.
A few moments later, Agent Paul landed a great
deal less smoothly, but still very much in
one piece.
The pilot was already dusting himself off
several feet away from the two men.
In the distance, they could hear the booming
sound of the helicopter crashing, and Agent
Adams winced.
"Poor guy."
"Poor us."
Agent Paul added.
"Where are we, anyway?"
"Somewhere in Maine."
The pilot shrugged.
"Small town nearby, from the looks of it."
He pointed toward a nearby sign, and the other
two men sighed with relief.
Civilization.
Somewhere they could get cleaned up, get a
bite to eat, and apologetically call for backup.
"Nice."
Agent Adams grinned.
"Paul, you're from this part of the country,
you know this town?
Derry?"
Agent Paul shook his head.
"No, I've never even heard of it."
Agent Adams shrugged, and he, Agent Paul,
and the pilot slowly made their way into the
unassuming little town of Derry, Maine.
It was lovely, idyllic even, such a picture
of small-town bliss that they didn't even
notice just how many "Missing" posters were
stapled to the telephone poles, the wide eyes
of lost children seeming to watch them as
they passed.
Meanwhile, on the other side of town, in the
middle of the marshy barrens where so many
children had gone missing that summer, and
the summer 27 years before it, a figure was
climbing out of the smoldering wreckage of
the helicopter.
It was big, and furry, with massive paws and
that silly metal helmet on top of its head.
SCP-2006 had survived and was taking its first
free steps in decades.
It looked around at the wilderness, the trees,
the rocks, the running water, and the entrance
to the town's sewers.
It barely understood any of what it was seeing,
but it knew that it was in a brand new place,
one that would hopefully be filled with brand
new people to scare.
Oh, how exciting to think about seeing new
faces, eyes wide with dread, mouths open in
screams!
The creature was in its favorite, most fearsome
form, too!
The mighty and terrible Ro-Man from the 1953
classic "Robot Monster."
None could behold this shape without collapsing
in terror.
SCP-2006 clapped its hands together delightedly,
laughing to itself.
It had been nervous, when the helicopter started
to fall out of the sky.
But now?
It seemed like that was the best thing that
could have possibly happened!
With no one in the immediate vicinity to frighten,
2006 decided to wander off through the woods
in search of fresh victims.
After all, now that it was free from that
awful box, there was plenty of time to look,
and an endless amount of scares to be given!
The creature ambled down the road, past a
public park, a vintage diner, and rows and
rows of little houses.
A woman passed, walking her dog.
SCP-2006 roared at her, expanding its arms
wide and standing up on its tiptoe to appear
as large as possible.
"FEAR ME!
FOR I AM RO-MAN!"
"That's nice, dear."
The lady passively remarked, stopping to let
her dog sniff 2006's leg.
It lifted its own leg, and urinated on the
creature's fur.
"How DARE YOU!
I am MONSTROUS!
Quake with fear!"
2006 bellowed, but the lady only chuckled,
shook her head, and continued on her way.
Puzzled, the creature continued to walk along
the road, looking for more victims to terrorize
and strike fear into their fragile hearts.
Up ahead, a group of little children playing
with a soccer ball.
Perfect.
2006 crouched low to the ground, and snuck
up on the group, hiding behind a bush before
popping out with a wild yell.
"TREMBLE BEFORE THE MIGHTY RO-MAN!"
It shouted.
One child screamed, startled, but his friends
immediately began to tease him.
"Calm down ya big baby, it's just a guy in
a suit."
One of his friends thumped him with the soccer
ball.
Another boy, who was eating a cherry popsicle,
laughed loudly at the sight of the entity.
"Nice costume, loser."
He blew a raspberry, and threw the popsicle
at 2006's head, sugary frozen slurry dripping
down its fur.
"Why aren't you afraid?"
SCP-2006 demanded, unable to grasp how it
had lost its scaring abilities so quickly.
Perhaps something had gone wrong during the
crash, or perhaps this town was just filled
with unusually brave people.
Whatever it was, 2006 wanted to figure out
the answer, and fast.
After all, who was SCP-2006 if it wasn't scary?
"Because we're not scared of some nerd in
a Chewbacca suit, barf bag!"
The kid with the soccer ball threw it at 2006,
who caught it, its claws puncturing the ball
and flattening it.
"Hey, this doofus broke our ball!
Kick his butt!"
"It is you who should be concerned with your
butts!"
SCP-2006 retorted, changing its face to the
shape of a werewolf from a classic black and
white film.
It bared its teeth, rubbery tongue lolling
out of its mouth, glassy eyes staring in two
different directions.
"Woah, how'd you do that?"
The angry boy lowered his fists, gaping in
awe.
"Never mind, that was kind of cool."
"Bummer about the ball though."
The first boy sighed.
Fed up with all of this confusion, SCP-2006
dropped the deflated ball to the ground, then
promptly turned and walked in the opposite
direction.
"Hey, where's he going?!"
The kids demanded, but the anomaly did not
respond.
One boy began bragging about his new collection
of baseball cards, and their attention was
soon pulled away from the strange being that
they believed to be a person in a monster
costume.
Then, as SCP-2006 walked, it heard the sound
it had been waiting to hear all day.
Screams, glorious screams of absolute terror,
the purest sound of fear.
It sounded like a child, shrieking at the
top of their lungs in the face of something
truly horrifying.
Where could that wonderful noise be coming
from?
And why hadn't SCP-2006 been the one to inspire
it?!
The anomaly was desperate to get to the bottom
of things.
It followed the sound, searching for its source,
but just as the sound grew louder and the
creature got closer, it cut off all of a sudden,
as if swallowed up by something all-encompassing.
"Hello?!"
SCP-2006 called out, in vain.
"Where did you go?
Come back, so that I can scare you!
Please!
...I am Ro-Man!"
"Hiya there, Ro-Man!"
A voice piped up from behind the entity.
It spun around, looking for whoever just spoke.
"Hello?
Who is it?"
SCP-2006 could not see anyone, only the suburban
street, the houses, the empty yards.
"Down here!"
The voice called.
"This way!"
The voice was coming from a storm drain, down
in the darkness below.
SCP-2006 could just barely make out a pair
of eyes, a white painted face, a red nose,
and a pair of bright red lips.
"BOO!"
SCP-2006 shouted at the person in the storm
drain.
It burst into a fit of giggles.
"Oh, that was very good.
What's your name?"
The clown asked.
"I am Ro-Man, the mighty, the fearsome!"
SCP-2006 replied.
"Nice to meet ya.
I'm Pennywise, the dancing clown!"
The clown grinned, showing a mouth full of
sharp teeth.
"Come a little closer, why don't ya.
Maybe we could be friends."
SCP-2006 was perplexed, but approached just
the same.
The clown took a deep breath, catching a whiff
of the entity's unfamiliar scent, and it frowned.
"What are you?"
Pennywise asked, the friendly affectation
gone from its voice and face.
"You don't smell right to me...not like anything
I've ever smelled."
"I told you.
Are you scared?"
2006 replied.
Pennywise laughed at this, a wild unhinged
cackle.
"I'm not scared of you.
Are you scared?"
The clown stared at 2006, its wide orange
eyes glinting in the light.
"Of course not.
I'm much scarier than you are."
"You're funny!"
The clown exclaimed.
"Very funny.
Why don't you come down here with me?
Want to float?
We all do, down here."
"I'm not funny."
SCP-2006 pouted.
"I'm scary."
"Sure, sure, whatever you say."
The clown waved the words away.
"Don't you want to come over here?
We could be friends."
Cautiously, the anomaly approached the storm
drain, leaning down to get a better look at
the strange clown.
Suddenly, the clown's hand shot out, grabbing
hold of SCP-2006's arm.
The clown's mouth stretched open wide, revealing
row upon row of teeth, and a seemingly impossible
stretch of darkness inside of its jaws.
Pennywise bit down on the anomaly's arm, pulling
it into the storm drain, trying to swallow
it whole like a snake swallows its prey.
But as it tried to devour SCP-2006, it began
to choke, its body rejecting the entity, and
it spat the furry anomaly back out.
SCP-2006 landed in the water inside of the
sewer with a wet plop, as Pennywise rubbed
at its jaw thoughtfully.
"Hm.
You really are strange."
The clown frowned.
"I told you before, I'm scary.
I'm scary!"
SCP-2006 insisted.
"Sure you are."
Pennywise grimaced.
"Is that the shape you use?
To scare people?"
SCP-2006 nodded.
"Among others.
This is my most successful, though."
Pennywise shook its head.
"I know a thing or two about fear, it's what
I use to season my meat.
Fear is what I do.
And you?
You've got a lot to learn about fear."
"Would you...show me?
How to be more scary?"
SCP-2006 asked.
Pennywise laughed again, a hacking, coughing
sound.
"You know what?
I will.
The more frightened children in this town,
the better.
As long as you understand, this is my turf."
SCP-2006 nodded furiously.
"I understand!"
Pennywise beckoned the entity over, and motioned
for it to sit down.
"Fear is...personal.
Everyone is afraid of something different,
and there is a unique way to tap into each
person's deepest fears.
Normally, I look like this.
Like Pennywise, the Dancing Clown.
Clowns are funny, children like clowns, but
they're also...terrified of clowns."
Pennywise did a little jig, laughing wildly.
"It makes them taste so sweet, when they meet
me like this and think I'm a friend, and then...I
show them what I truly am."
The clown bared its teeth.
"Humans aren't scared of clowns."
SCP-2006 shook its head.
"In my experience, they only think clowns
are funny.
They laugh at them.
Now this is scary..."
SCP-2006 concentrated, and changed its shape.
It was a giant rabbit, from the film Night
of the Lepus.
"This strikes terror into their hearts."
"No, it doesn't."
Pennywise rolled its eyes.
"Listen to me.
Suppose, a child has a fear of birds.
Maybe he watched a movie about a giant pterodactyl,
maybe he was attacked by a bird as a baby.
Maybe it was both.
You could try something like this."
Pennywise shifted forms then, changing from
a clown to a giant bird, with sharp talons,
a massive wingspan, a pointed beak, and wild
eyes.
"Or say the child is afraid to cross a stream,
because he's afraid of piranhas..."
The shape of Pennywise changed again, as piranhas
plopped into the water below, swimming around
in a ravenous swarm.
"So...being scary is about animals?"
SCP-2006 cocked its head to the side, confused.
Pennywise resumed its clown form, growing
increasingly frustrated.
"No, it's...it's about a person's darkest
thoughts, the images that come to them while
they lie in bed and struggle to fall asleep.
Say...there's a little boy who lives in fear
of sickness.
His mother planted the fear in his head, you
see.
All day long, he imagines little bacteria
crawling across his skin, infections waiting
to slip inside and rot him from the inside
out.
To him, I would look like this..."
Pennywise changed into the shape of a leper,
a man covered with sores and limbs about to
drop off, with a hacking, diseased cough.
Then, whoosh, it was a clown again.
"Or say there's a girl who fears one person
more than anyone else in the world: her father.
A man who was once kind to her, maybe, but
loss, anger, and drink have turned him wrong.
Made anger curdle into violence inside his
heart.
To her, I would only need to look like him,
to say all of the things she's afraid he thinks..."
Pennywise looked at SCP-2006.
"Do you understand now?"
"I think so!"
The anomaly chirped.
"So I should try something like this!"
It transformed into something large, smooth,
and slimy.
It was one of the frogs from the 1972 film,
"Frogs."
"This will bring any person to their knees
with fright!"
"NO!"
Pennywise bellowed.
"No, no, no, no, no!
You don't get it!
So many things are scary, spiders, being abandoned
by your friends, being unloved, being buried
alive, a man with no head, a missing poster
for someone who isn't missing yet.
But you?
You're not scary, you're not scary at all!"
SCP-2006 huffed.
"Even when I do this?"
It turned into the shape of a fluffy alien
with glowing red eyes and decidedly fake-looking
papier mache arms.
Pennywise the Dancing Clown sat down on the
ground, resting his head in his hands with
a long, exhausted sigh.
"Listen, kid.
I thought this would be fun, but...I'm just
so tired.
You're not scary.
I can't eat you.
What am I supposed to do with you?
I've got a good thing going here, and I have
for a very, very long time.
You being here?
It's messing things up.
Just...Get out of my town, you're embarrassing
me.
Go on, get out of Derry.
Find some other town to "scare," this one's
full."
b
"Well, you didn't have to be so rude about
it."
SCP-2006 huffed, but it listened just the
same.
It left Derry, Maine behind, walking off down
the open road, just in time for an unmarked
van from the SCP Foundation to pull up beside
it, and open the door.
"Ro-Man!"
Called out Agent Paul.
"You're very frightening, and we almost didn't
stop because you frightened us so much, but...do
you need a ride?
In exchange for promising not to tear us apart
with your mighty claws, of course."
"Will you take me to more people I can scare?"
2006 asked.
Agent Paul hid his smile, and beckoned the
creature inside.
"You got it, buddy."
Now go check out “SCP-2006 - Too Spooky”
and “25 Most Frightening SCP” for more
terrifying journeys into the world of the
SCP Foundation!